slides a prankster the slide is very
mischievous so he definitely finds ways
to stir stir the pot a little bit
changed labels on things around said
he's just he's a very mischievous
devious guy so it's always fun with him
also new in theaters this weekend Creed
to Ralph breaks the internet and Robin
Hood what will you see this is your
weekend ticket
[Music]
the only movie we're getting off to a
rocky start
is a good thing cream 2 comes out this
weekend this sequel to Creed and the 8th
overall installment of the rocky
franchise follows the continued efforts
of the Creed family trying to get rid of
their drama-filled baggage rewrite
history if you will to fight this man
that's your business
but don't pretend this is about your
father
Adonis Creed played by Michael B Jordan
must now defeat the son of Ivan Drago
who killed his own father Apollo Creed
33 years ago there were me I'd just
leave a bunch of prank calls on their
message machines
hold on cases Ivan Ivan Drago you suck
we can't baby this movie is for you if
you like Friday Night Lights abour black
panthers own Michael B Jordan the rocky
franchise got you all Adrian or you've
always wished Family Feud raise the
stakes a bit
survey says punched in the face
also in theaters this weekend Ralph
breaks the Internet john c reilly
returns as wreck-it Ralph in the sequel
to the original 3d animated comedy
adventure we're going the Internet Ralph
and vanellope voiced by Sarah Silverman
team up to save the inhabitants of the
sugar rush game and take to the World
Wide Web
in search of a replacement steering
wheel this movie is for you if you like
your Rijal wreck-it Ralph you're looking
for a great family-friendly animated
adventure for the weekend or you just
upgraded to a smartphone for the first
time ever and you need an
easy-to-understand depiction of how
technology works yeah I know HTML how to
made ladies and finally the latest
iteration of the classic Robin Hood
story hits the big screen this weekend
with taran Edgerton as lead who do you
think the thief is
clearly he's well-trained adaptable
under fire go get him eventually the
cast also features Jamie Bock
Ben Mendelsohn Eve Hewson and Jamie
Dornan this spin on the classic story
still has the typical tropes of romance
and avenging the marginalized but with
the action-packed super-slow-motion
gritty fight scenes this movie is for
you if you like modern twists on classic
adventure stories you like seeing Taran
kick butt like in the Kingsmen movies or
you love it any version of Robin Hood
tights wearing for uber fashionable that
is your weekend ticket what will you see
check back next week for Hannah grace is
worth day
[Music]